Radio learned to make pictures and the
country continued to amaze itself in
the world at large this finale is the
television gaming equipment you know
that's the thing I've been broadcasting for
a long time but this will be the first time
the radio audience will be able to both
see and hear me broadcasting at the same
time and another wonderful thing they won't
be able to throw great food at me with this
machine will they no they certainly won't now
we're going to televise a picture of yourself
and thank you into the other room the let
you see this picture I've been over the air
there was something in the air besides saucers
you didn't need binoculars to find it either
he just didn't go through a shop window there
was another post-war wonder right before your
eyes television the audience eventually
came in off the sidewalk and television
got to be very big in the Barros it was
off to the races in more ways than one
I want a spread from the saloon to the house next
door everybody had to have
it pretty soon everybody did
then remember caesar and coca in the show of shows
and Dave Garroway garraway
lines oh and say Emerson
and the Kukla peloton's Kukla Fran and Ollie and
of course the man who owned Tuesday night uncle
Miltie with time and Miranda but it wasn't
all fun and games television also brought us
over reminders that we were living in ominous
times dr. out in Moscow the French and Russians
have agreed on the adaptation of the modified
French color television process see can free
and will recommend its use for all Europe at
the Oslo conference to be held in June after
extensive tests including a transmission by the
Soviet satellite ammonia one the Russians have
now accepted the system industrial production
will start in both France and Russia in 1967